there how the [ __ ] how do you reach that
subject with your wife like hey let me
ask you a question you like eating
people I'll buy you you defy me I bet
you want to eat me I do do you want to
eat me yeah do you want to eat somebody
so you know I mean how do you how do you
get into that level of perversion some
dark [ __ ] it's some dark [ __ ] but I
guess they found each other they
probably saw each other and they're like
I'd like to eat that person what if
let's say you would eat me let's just
say you had to what part would you eat
first on you yeah and then I'll say well
you got some good meat on you where but
you got a pic part of the back of your
arm
you'd eat my tricep wasn't me tough me
it'd be some tough meat right oh you're
chi-chi's your little chica pues let's
see we got some cute chiku's
sure got all soft each cheek yes what
what gross no no no dude yeah there ya
on the show you said I'd eat your ass
and you're like and you were looking me
in the eye
no you're G you're attracted to me no
like I would bet the a today I would
barbecue your ass cheese oh you guys I
said I want to eat your ass I'd eat your
ass it's so gross dude
what would you do peel my peach go to
hell no no Santa no I would skin enough
like you want to go after my flat at all
bro prashant prosciutto shoot though bro
no you said you'd eat my cheeks on my
triceps how's that any different I'm
training your glutes no because you went
I'd eat your ass and you said it without
like you said it all loose mouth state
all open yeah Brooke you're high no it
came out wrong you worried me cuz you're
strong mate I eat your hamstring you
hold me down I get off I'd pickle your
ankles you would at pickle your ankles
your old ass ankles feel like you'd be
like pretty wrong there's anxiety to get
better and come up with new bits and
come up with you know new material and
didn't do this but it's not the the
comedy bits
a boogeyman anymore it's like a good
stress yeah and it's exciting right it's
exciting yeah that's initially up in
fighting my grandma he said best is it
like I remember after every fight I
before she passed away I'd go to her
house in Aurora I would drive that after
every fight and she wouldn't watch them
they've never watched him she'd wait to
get a call from my mom or someone and
after every fight go there she goes
how'd it go I go I'd win and I tell her
and she'd always go did anyone really
win she goes did you get punched in the
face here oh yeah she was did he upon
space he oh yeah she was then no one
wins rent geez no one ever wins you're
both losers No
very cool thank you thank you for that
but she's right like in the fight
business
everyone's getting brain trauma winners
losers you get a brain trauma you get a
brain trauma you get a brain trauma the
boogeyman that's he's dishing out like
Oprah dishes out Priuses hey everyone's
gettin brain trauma you win financially
gasps I guess account how scared was
wussy to start a podcast do it
Godfather's a podcast you say that dude
but I [ __ ] did it
you threw you out okay well how many
thirsty questions the ask about pocket I
say the facts and this is not a plea we
were standing there and and don't get
upset and then I'm spilling the beans
you threw yourself at our feet and your
face yeah see and your face was on the
ground it was dirty dude please help
please help me no don't I see you said I
didn't do you threw yourself you threw
yourself a fee and the the reverberation
of the ground made you fart a little I
helped you to eat nice and I slapped you
around a little bit to wake you up and
then I I didn't I put you in order did
you say you you think you said rise and
I rose no it didn't happen yeah
and then you set 20,000 texts I got a
text from Chloe you know why cuz you
don't get
Aquin needs some this especially listen
get your finger out of my face
here's what Chris sent me yesterday
these usually went to that he went to
eat and I wasn't there I was hanging
still at the store and I get a text and
said just a picture of food what was it
Anna Kenny and I get this text come
instantly and that I didn't answer and
he goes I said instantly no and then I
came then as I was left I got this text
I driving home you're welcome for
everything mm-hmm well I [ __ ] rocked
it dude and I don't get appreciation I
rocked it you shouldn't reach others
text ads on a podcast well no because
food no because sometimes you want a
show to come to a screeching halt right
right still for that I'll read some
podcast yeah pretends he knows MMA oh
dude
if there's one thing I know it's MMA
yeah Bella door bell la Tour